in the batman viewers see the first ever
electric batmobile
to get this blue fire look practically
the team had to pivot to electric to
avoid fires on set and put a jet intake
under its hood to make it look like it
was breathing this fits right in with
the batman franchise's commitment to
in-camera effects as the films have
pulled off some of the batmobile's most
impressive feats with minimal cgi
here's how six other memorable stunts
came to life
christopher nolan's version of the
batmobile the tumbler looks like a cross
between a hummer a tank and a
lamborghini and because the director was
set on capturing the movie's police
chase in camera this tank-like car had
to be fast and maneuverable so the team
constructed the batmobile with side
mounted wheels and no front axle which
allowed it to pull off super tight turns
and designed its six wheels to act
independently of each other so that one
could stop while the other rotated to
make the car change direction on a dime
that meant this batmobile could actually
execute those sharp moves you see in the
movies
it could also jump six feet in height
and 60 feet in distance and really did
run over the two cop cars in this shot a
move the team practiced before the shoot
stunt driver george caudle trained for
the police chase for months by taking
the batmobile for laps on a closed race
track when it came time to film in
chicago the stunt team tracked the
batmobile with a device called the
ultimate arm a high-speed high torque
robotic camera crane that could spin 360
degrees attached to the top of a
mercedes this allowed them to get car to
car tracking shots at speeds of up to 90
miles per hour
despite the tumbler's impressive specs
there was one move it couldn't do
jump across the rooftops of gotham
so the crew decided to do this stunt
with miniatures 1-3 scale models of the
gotham set and batmobile the team
replicated key details of the full-scale
car on the mini remote controlled model
so that the two versions of the
batmobile would drive as similarly as
possible
the model needed to drive at around 35
miles per hour which may not sound like
much but is pretty fast for a miniature
to match the background of the miniature
footage to the location in chicago the
crew extensively photographed the entire
shooting area and took detailed notes on
the location's lighting tying it all
together were the finishing touches
added digitally including camera lens
effects cg car headlights moving
reflections vapor plumes and debris like
these shattering roof tiles you see as
the batmobile sticks its landing
after the location shoot in chicago the
team had to tackle another seemingly
impossible stunt for the very end of the
chase when the batmobile makes its
dramatic return through a waterfall at
the mouth of the bat cave they shot the
takeoff for real on a field but the
landing was filmed on the batcave set in
the uk there the team made a full-scale
waterfall using 12 water pumps to run 14
000 gallons of water through the set
using huge high pressure nitrogen
cannons they catapulted the over two and
a half ton batmobile through the
waterfall sands driver this was risky so
they used a restraining cable to stop
the car right upon landing preventing it
from hurtling through the other end of
the extremely expensive set
when christopher nolan saw that the
batmobile could jump up to 60 feet he
decided to take it a step further in the
dark knight
the movie's chase would involve the
batmobile jumping over another car
intercepting the joker's grenade and
then getting destroyed in a very
spectacular way
since this would all take place in a
tunnel stunt driver george caudle had to
execute the jump perfectly too much
height and he'd hit the concrete above
the stunt team built a ramp at just the
right height and angle that they could
tow behind the other car and created a
big button for cuddle to press inside
the batmobile so that he could trigger
the explosion himself the key was timing
it he had to wait until the car was at
the top of its ark when he just began to
feel it come down
the car exploded from the back and to
keep cuddles safe it had explosion-proof
gas tanks like the kind used on race
cars so that if the tanks got punctured
they wouldn't actually explode
[Applause]
the final installment of the dark knight
trilogy introduces the batwing which
serves as batman's new ride after a
bunch of tumblers fall into the hands of
bane's henchmen
this time around the team had to make
batman's vehicle fly and because it's a
christopher nolan movie they had to do
it with as little cgi as possible
the special effects team built two real
versions of the bat both were massive at
28 feet long and 17 feet wide there was
a lighter version that the team could
lift up on cables which were removed in
post to create the illusion of flight
then there was a heavier version which
weighed one and a half tons and had
working guns that fired via remote
control the team mounted this bat on a
truck with a hydraulic crane and drove
it through the streets of pittsburgh at
50 miles an hour the vfx team removed
the support car and crane in post
while the bat could be driven in a
straight line and could even swerve it
wasn't great at going around corners at
high speeds
so for those shots where the bat did
especially wild maneuvers the vfx team
had to replace the practical bat with a
digital replica selling it wasn't easy
much of the dark knight rises takes
place in the daytime unusual for a
batman movie that coupled with the
decision to shoot the film in imax meant
the level of detail on the cg bat had to
stand up to a super high resolution
under full lighting
luckily the vfx artists had the
advantage of new technology a physically
based ray tracing system partly
developed a pixar ray tracing is a
technique of mapping out all the rays of
light in a scene as they bounce off
different objects and characters before
artists would have had to grade the
surface of the cg bat by hand
now the software helped automate that
process which made it easier to mimic
the shadows and highlights on every inch
of the real thing
ben affleck's 8
800 pound batmobile took over a year to
build so how are they going to film
shots like this
the team created not one but three
batmobiles well sort of
there was the real deal that affleck
drove with a full interior cockpit then
there were two proxy cars which they
called smash mobiles basically stripped
down dodge ram dooleys
when any shots called for the batmobile
to collide with other objects the
filmmakers used one of the smash mobiles
instead shooting on location in the
streets of detroit actually doing the
stunts with a stand-in car gave the vfx
artists a practical starting point so
when the vfx team digitally swapped the
smash mobile for the batmobile in post
the action looked much more grounded
it's that commitment to practical
methods that has brought this car to
life again and again and turn it into
its very own character in the films
so what do you think